hi guys I'm Tati Gabrielle and this is
your Sabrina spoiler alert now that
you've been to part three now it's time
to talk about all those - its I don't
want anything from you Nick and Sabrina
breakup was devastating absolutely a
really really really tough thing to do
filming the scene it was lovely though
yeah but when you saw crew members
sniffling there's something that you
just feel like you've done your job it's
sad it's so sad especially like you know
we our world is one that's like there's
so much terminal turmoil going on all
that all the time and and so so many new
new challenges new stakes and some
comfort is always nice and so it's
really sad that you know through all of
this chaos that you know everybody's
kind of lonely and it's a cold world out
in Greendale these shakeups in
relationships they happen in the real
world as they do in the fictional one
and you know are supposed to reflect
like you know you're saving yourself for
someone else and we both know who that's
not fair and that's not true but no it
is it's hard to see them separate but I
think it's essential yeah it's at that
particular moment of them let them go
right that's the saying goes what they
say hey scratch how's it going
aren't ginko how's it going with you you
asking which team we're on oh you're
asking us right and I can't really
choose and if you did choose there will
they just swap around and be with
another one anyway there's I can't keep
can't keep I so I am still a very firm
hub Rena fan but I'm also a very firm
Harvey cause I don't know what you want
to call that but if I had to put Sabrina
with someone because Nick really messed
up this season man he did a lot of dirty
things and Caliban is crazy
she's crazy because Sabrina is Harvey
they want I'm so sorry are are so loving
it's so cute there's a part of me that
just wants to see them together because
there's a young love but clearly
Nicholas scratch is dare I say the
superior choice listen to what I was so
team hey Brina at first 'no Brina
obviously oh I think it's beautiful
their love I don't know her love is real
their love is probably powerful and I
think they're better suited for each
other but there's the yeah I think you
can do both I would be I would be happy
to see so we're gonna end up with a high
they're gonna call you okay young men or
both yeah
dude relax it was just a question I
think it's always good for a girl to
spend some time on her own as well yeah
well said I second that know what
Sabrina's gonna stay single I'm gonna
say a strong woman and she doesn't need
a man to make her any better or to make
her yeah she's just great by herself
that's my answer
believe it or not I have more important
things to deal with in your drama and
narcissism right now
[Music]